لقد كان طريقًا طويلاً ، ولكن مع استمرار تطور التكنولوجيا ،
فإن العلاج الجيني يعد طريقة رائعة إلى حد
كبير لتقديم الطب aa إلى الدماغ من
خلال الوسائل الجينية
.  مؤلف دراسة نُشرت في
Nature Communications
تضمنت أبحاثهم سبعة
مرضى تتراوح أعمارهم بين 4 و
9 سنوات
يعانون من اضطراب وراثي
نادر يتسبب في إعاقات
جسدية ونمائية شديدة ، استخدم بانكوفيتش وزملاؤه طريقة جديدة
للعلاج الجيني
الذي غرس فيروسًا حميدًا  مبرمجة
بحمض نووي محدد
في مناطق مستهدفة بدقة من
الدماغ ،
ثم تتبع الأطباء انتشار
الفيروس في الدماغ من خلال
التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي في الوقت الحقيقي ، مما يسمح لنا
بإدخال النسخة الصحيحة
من الجين إلى الخلايا
في أدمغة هؤلاء الأطفال.
تحسنت أعراض المريض
بشكل كبير
ويأمل الباحثون بهذه الطريقة
يمكن استخدام العلاج الجيني لعلاج
الاضطرابات الوراثية الأخرى بالإضافة إلى
الأمراض التنكسية العصبية الشائعة والأكثر تعقيدًا مثل
مرض باركنسون والزهايمر.
لقد تعلمناهم
من أخطائنا ،
واصلنا تحسين ما نقوم
به وهذا أعتقد أننا نسير على
الطريق الصحيح هنا من أجل دقيقة صحية ، أنا ماندي
غايثر